the
origin of the idea was just how do you
make the luxury bridal experience
accessible
to the 99 i'm molly king i'm the founder
and ceo of floravera and i graduated
from the gsb class of 2015.
so florivera were on a mission to really
revolutionize the entire bridal industry
by offering
luxury bridal gowns and a truly luxury
intimate private experience for shopping
for your gown with
radical price points that have never
existed before
so it's been a while since i've seen
that video
yeah it's kind of blowing my mind the
difference
how i don't even know however many
months since we did this can make
how drastically what your life looks
like can change is
is kind of sad and probably going to
make me emotional
you know you have all these big dreams
and plans
and we had so many things planned for
2020 you know we were operating for four
years but really two years in earnest
and we had
opened 13 showrooms in 13 different
cities across the u.s
and then in march 2020
kovit happened and
practically overnight we closed all of
our showrooms
and the state of weddings in general in
the u.s
was suddenly in limbo you know it's it's
ironic to look back in my early pitches
to investors i always said the beauty of
this business is that it's
recession-proof because people will
always be getting married
but it was not pandemic proof my
professor one of my professors from the
gsb
he was sort of the one that mentored me
through my second year and really
convinced me to launch this business
he said to me you know molly in in life
and career
success is often just timing and luck
and so you were at the wrong place at
the wrong time but he said mark my words
six years from now seven years from now
there will be an incredibly successful
business that looks just like yours
the part about it that surprised me
through this time was
how supportive my investors were through
that time
and then they then turned around and
said what do you want to do next
and many of those investors are
investors either that i'd met at the gsb
or through the gsb network
on a professional level the big
breakthrough that i had
is that i still want to be an
entrepreneur which
um on one hand sounds crazy
i have these two close friends who also
started companies right when we
graduated together they were my
graduating class the three of us
have had monthly calls every month for
the past five years since we've
graduated
and when i told them gosh you know i
think i want to do this all over again
and
what are some ideas you guys want to
brainstorm some ideas together they
thought i was insane
they said if you right now in this
moment after what's happened to your
business
still want to do this again that must
really mean that you're meant to be an
entrepreneur
i would very much like to build a new
brand build a new product
and to continue trying my hand in
[Music]
entrepreneurship
you